Sofía es dueña de una granja con mucho
ganado este año tenía un total de 300
vacas y sus cultivos proporcionaron un
suministro anual de alimento de 8
toneladas de eno por cada vaca ella
descubrió que el número de vacas se
duplica cada año es decir en el primer
año va a tener 300 vacas pero en el
siguiente año va a tener el doble de 300
vacas es decir van a haber 600 vacas y
después el doble 10000 y así
sucesivamente Mientras que el suministro
de eno que sus cultivos proporcionan por
cada vaca eso es muy importante por cada
vaca se multiplica por 1.5 cada año
recuerda que cada una de las vacas come
anualmente 8 toneladas de eno Así que lo
que nos está diciendo aquí es que por
cada vaca el sub ministro de eno va a
aumentar en proporción de 1.5 cada año
después nos dice la función cdt devuelve
el número de vacas que hay en la granja
de Sofía de años a partir de ahora la
función fdt devuelve el suministro anual
de eno por vaca producido en la granja
de Sofía en toneladas de años a partir
de ahora y después nos dice encuentra la
fórmula de las dos funciones que es
justo lo que quieren en este ejercicio
así que qué te parece si empezamos con
cdt quién era cdt bueno la función cdt
devuelve el número de vacas que hay en
la granja de Sofía t años a partir de
ahora es una función que depende de T T
es el tiempo y está dado en años ahora
date cuenta que empezamos con 300 vacas
así que por aquí voy a poner 300 voy a
empezar con 300 vacas Pero estas 300
vacas se van duplicando cada año que
pase Y para poner que se duplican bueno
podría poner aquí que se multiplican por
dos así que lo voy a poner se
multiplican por dos hay que tener
cuidado en el siguiente año voy a tener
600 vacas pero después voy a tener el
doble de 600 vacas y cómo puedo expresar
eso con relación al tiempo Bueno pues
sería multiplicar 300 * 2 que es 600 * 2
es decir estamos elevando al 2 a la
cantidad de años por lo tanto voy a
poner 300 que multiplica 2 que a su vez
está elevado a la cantidad de años a la
cantidad de de años y date cuenta que
esta fórmula tiene todo el sentido
lógico del mundo si nosotros queremos
saber la cantidad de vacas que hay
actualmente es decir no ha pasado ningún
año Me quedaría 300 que multiplica a 2
elevado a la 0 porque no ha pasado
ningún año y eso es exactamente lo mismo
que 2 a la 0 lo cual es 1 * 300
llegaríamos de nuevo a mis 300 vacas
iniciales después de que transcurra un
año Me quedaría 300 por 2 elevado a la
primera potencia lo cual es el doble de
300 que me da 600 vacas si yo quisiera
saber Cuántas vacas hay en el segundo
año después de que transcurra el segundo
año Me quedaría 300 * 2 cu lo cual es lo
mismo que 300 * 4 lo que es 10000 o
dicho otra manera 300 * 2 por 2 y así
por la cantidad de años ahora veamos Qué
representa fdt fdt es la función que
devuelve el suministro anual de eno por
vaca producido en la granja de Sofía en
toneladas de años a partir de ahora pero
qué nos dice el problema que el
suministro de eno que sus cultivos
proporcionan por cada vaca Eso está muy
bien porque aquí me piden por cada vaca
se multiplica por 1.5 cada año Así que
eso va a tener mucha lógica y va a ser
muy parecido a lo que tenemos aquí
nosotros empezamos con 8 toneladas de
eno por cada vaca y a esto lo voy a
multiplicar por bueno nuestro factor
pero en este caso nuestro factor va a
ser
1.5
1.5 por cada año después de transcurrido
el primer primer año me va a quedar 8 *
1.5 después de transcurrido 2 años me va
a quedar 8 * 1.5 * 1.5 se multiplica por
1.5 cada año lo que quiere decir que
aquí lo que me hace falta es Elevar esto
a la potencia t es decir a la cantidad
de años tiene mucha lógica y es muy
parecido a lo que tenemos aquí solamente
que esta vez está cambiando nuestro
factor de 2 a 1.5
ahora veamos qué más nos dice este
problema la función
hdt devuelve el suministro de eno anual
Total ya no por cada vaca sino en total
producido en la granja de Sofía en
toneladas t años a partir de ahora y Es
que esto es muy importante es el
suministro de eno anual total lo que
quiere decir que en un principio
teníamos 300 vacas pero cada una de
ellas come 8 toneladas de eno eso quiere
decir que si quisiéramos encontrar hdt
en el primer año habría que multiplicar
300 Por 8 300 vacas por 8 toneladas por
cada vaca y así obtendríamos el
suministro de eno anual total pero nos
piden que escribamos la fórmula hdt en
términos de cdt Y fdt si en un principio
multiplicamos estas dos y cdt me dice la
cantidad de vacas que voy a tener t años
a partir de ahora y fdt me dice el
suministro anual de eno por vaca
producido en la granja de años a partir
de ahora Bueno entonces ahora tiene
mucho sentido que para obtener este
suministro de eno anual total habrá que
multiplicar estas dos funciones la
cantidad de vacas por la cantidad de eno
que consume cada vaca por lo tanto lo
voy a poner Aquí voy a tener a cdt c con
mayú
por aquí voy a ocupar esto cdt y a esto
lo voy a multiplicar por la otra función
mi otra función es F que es una función
de T esta c parece que no es mayúscula
Así que déjame ponerla de nuevo con
mayúscula cdt por
fdt ahora escribe esa misma Fórmula hdt
en términos de T bueno lo único que hay
que hacer es multiplicar estas dos y qué
me quedaría podemos reducir un poco me
quedaría 8 * 300 8 * 3 es 24 y dos ceros
esto a su vez que multiplica bueno
primero tengo 2 esto elevado a la
potencia t ya esto habrá que
multiplicarlo por
1.5
1.5 esto elevado a la potencia t de lujo
y ya con esto tengo la de hdt en
términos de T lo único que hice fue
sustituir estas dos fórmulas Aquí y
ahora sí es el momento de comprobar
nuestra respuesta y de lujo estamos bien
hasta el próximo
video